yo what's up though man it's t Grizzly
check me out on a bootleg Kev podcast
let's get it
bootleg Capt show special guests in here
my guy it's been too long been too long
man T Grizzly my brother good to see you
again bro you've been outside yeah I
never went inside during the pandemic
even outside man I've been trying and
listen you've been inside running up a
check you know what I'm saying I've been
on Twitch I've been on GTA dog you gotta
help me understand because I just saw
this clip of you asking a little kid
if he was gonna pick his mom or the
homies and then you smoked him and then
you drove off
what the [ __ ] is this role playing GTA
explain this thing yeah so you want me
explain that situation yes let's just
start off with that because okay so
basically right it was it was just I
could tell he was young you feel me
but he was already deep off the edge
into the streets you know what I'm
saying and he wanted to join Grizzly
game
you know so I'm like all right bet you
know I'm gonna show you everything and
see if this is what you really want so I
showed him everything right so now at
this point
if we don't put them down he gotta go
because he know too much
so I asked him a question the last part
initiation I was about to put him in
Grizzly game ask my question I said
this your new family now ain't no ain't
your regular family this over this Trump
everything once you become a part of
this you know what I'm saying so I asked
him I'm like bro I'm actually a question
don't hesitate
you feel me because if you hesitate at
me you gotta think about it I need you
to be sure I'm like so who your favorite
person in your family like my brother
I'm like all right bet if your brother's
standing right here and one of the
members standing right here and you got
to shoot when I'm Who you gonna shoot he
hesitated so he had to go so you killed
him yeah wow
I really need to get to the roots of
this entire world so
by the way I'm so happy for you that you
have because I think it's incredible
that you have uh
turned your love for gaming into like a
real incredible like stream of income
um
I don't understand the role-playing
thing so it's a it's it's like a server
you have your own server yeah I got my
own server Grizzly World RP so in this
world this is like you have a gang yeah
and when you guys are in the world on
the headphones and [ __ ] y'all are like
really acting yeah like acting like
that's the real world when we on there
right we don't know the real world don't
exist like that's the real world wow
that's deep it's kind of like Dungeons
and Dragons but like on a video game
kinda do you remember Dungeons and
Dragons yeah yeah that's crazy yeah
you know what it's exactly like that but
but funner yeah what's the Grand Theft
Auto it's crazy
will you uh are you like kind of sad
that the new GTA is coming it means
you're gonna probably eventually have to
retire the OG no
to the whole new build that's gonna be
better I can't wait for it to drop so
okay take me to the roots of this so
obviously you're a fan of video gaming
you've been gaming online at what point
in time do you get introduced to having
your own server role playing and
building this I mean you have like a
twitch Empire yeah it was it was during
covet bro it was during covert I was on
Call of Duty heavy streaming Call of
Duty and um somebody told me you got to
try GTA out right so I'll be on Call of
Duty Trolling right like then you you
gotta try GTA out right you feel me I
tried it I'm like no this [ __ ] actually
fun and my numbers went up on GTA yeah
because it's more entertaining I could
really like be myself on there yeah yeah
some Street [ __ ] you're running around
yeah exactly so that was like this is a
no-brainer and it just went up did you
ever think when you're sitting in a jail
cell
waiting to get out not knowing what was
on you know the other rest the side of
your life that you'd be getting paid the
amount of money you'd be getting paid to
play video games and act that's crazy
out the [ __ ] you used to do yeah I know
that existed bro
it's so crazy man yeah it's super crazy
for sure guys like yourself T-Pain's
been doing this thing you know I mean
yeah what has been your most successful
month on Twitch my most successful month
this month been very successful yeah
you've been going viral this month yeah
this might be very successful on Twitch
for sure and I ain't even been able to
stream not to be all in your pockets but
like what's that look like
it looked crazy like I could show you
like this month so far
and twitch got to start taking care of
their creators a little better so this
is because everything been going viral
so that's this one so far oh my God
yeah that's six figures yeah
can I say the amount a hundred fifteen
thousand dollars yeah in a month playing
video games oh yeah why would you ever
go to a club again
I don't male mad at me right now
male mad at me right now because um
I don't know I mean like this is the way
I look I can't show nobody like me that
you can make money from home because I
want to be home anyway well I was gonna
say like
you obviously can always put out music
uh but like why open yourself up to like
unnecessary risk for like 20 grand to go
to a club or do 30 grand to go to a club
when you could just chill at the crib
yeah be safe not worry about no [ __ ]
and uh you know just talk [ __ ] on the
internet it affects I don't do it though
I ain't been to a Cleveland it's been a
minute I was gonna say do you feel like
you're a professional gamer part-time
rapper now
um
I feel like I'm a professional gamer
part-time movie director
which is uh obviously coming out with it
with the project yeah yeah and um I
don't rapping no more bro
I just I just make movies now
straight up yeah so you're just kind of
it is what it is yeah
I'm I'm making a move I'm into the movie
thing now
and this is everybody rapping it's a new
rapper every day everybody rapping oh I
rap sound the same to me
so I just rather just do the movie thing
yeah there is a lot of rap sounding the
same
um you know what I appreciate about the
last few years is I just noticed
the Detroit for a long time felt like a
really divisive place when it came to
just obviously sides music people beef
with each other you've had your issues
with people whatever but I feel like
recently the last like six months to a
year it feels like everyone's kind of
moving in the same direction I feel like
you're very like out of the like drama
does that make sense does it make a lot
of sense I do it on purpose I don't want
to be involved no drama are you from the
east side or the west side or west side
okay west side yeah yeah I went to
Detroit for like a week a few months ago
and um it was fun man I actually really
enjoyed it great I mean the food was all
right I don't know if I went to the
wrong coneys or not
but the thing is when you in Detroit
getting food
not only do you know work I have to know
where to go right but you have to know
what to order that's fair you know what
I'm saying yeah because it's like a
thousand different colonies right each
specific Coney got the thing that they
the best at their own thing you know
what I'm saying yeah everyone was
telling me to go to trust is that what
it's called our truth truth the truth
the strip club they never made it over
there yeah I mean you ain't missed
nothing we did eat at uh ace of diamonds
yeah Ace of Spades yeah yeah it was it
was it wasn't bad Ace of Spades it's
over there somewhere mozzie was there
yeah yeah diamonds sound familiar
you got crazy girls
I mean I just want food at this point in
time yeah if I go to Crazy Girls I'm not
the type of person that's going to
compete if you go to Detroit you gotta
go to Pantheon get the lamb chops okay
Pantheon yeah we went to some terrible
place I think it was called Coliseum
Coliseum that's a little Museum looking
spot yeah well you know what it was was
uh yeah the lights yeah okay
I don't I've never been there
never been there Street Lord Juan sent
us there and I think he sent us there
because he knew that night we were like
we had nobody with Detroit with us so he
sent us to like an obvious White Strip
Club and I was so disappointed I walked
in and all these [ __ ] look like
Juggalos Grand Theft Auto dancers it was
terrible and the food was [ __ ] got
off yeah I've never been there before it
was it was bad yeah yeah it wasn't it
man but yeah shout out to Detroit I feel
like um
you know for you as somebody who
obviously in my opinion kicked the door
down for kind of the commercialization
of the new wave of Detroit hip-hop the
street [ __ ] yeah for sure
um how do you go as far as saying that's
an opinion like that's a fact yeah for
sure opinion is something that could be
disputed yeah I mean I think that you're
you're the most successful person
commercially who did Street Detroit
music that's a fact right so like but
now the wave is just so it's crazy not
all boys out there going crazy now for
sure they going crazy enough you know
obviously uh Sada baby baby money uh
everybody right even guys like payroll
Giovanni's still doing their thing
payroll just did some [ __ ] overseas I
was like damn I can't even go over there
and they was [ __ ] with him heavy
because of your uh prior criminal [ __ ]
yeah damn yes shout out to all them guys
though for sure were you like growing up
on the west side where it's like like
payrolling those guys like guys you
looked up to yeah
yeah absolutely payroll I looked up to
some guys up from the East side too for
sure but payroll on them they definitely
held it down for the West like that was
our champions for the west side for sure
yeah yeah I always hear like everyone
says like the difference between the two
sides is like uh the West side's a
little flashier
I would say so yeah does that make sense
yeah the west side I left last year a
little broker
East Side really don't really flash like
that but they'll be having a lot of
money type [ __ ] yeah but it's changed
now though it's changed because the East
Side getting flashy and the West Side
getting dirty you know what I'm saying
so it's changed the East Side used to be
you know them [ __ ] over there dirty
yeah not on the West Side looking dirty
as hell and the East Side looking good
yeah so it's been a shift how's uh like
for you uh does it feel good to just
kind of see your city prospering like
that man got me QC side two people from
the see they feel great they feel great
it feel amazing yeah you know I just
wish we had a better mindset about [ __ ]
but you know it feel amazing seeing it
though yeah what do you mean by that
though like
Detroit
is very divided it's very divided for so
everybody
we really ain't trying to stick together
we our mindset from Detroit like we
gonna do us and we gonna win regardless
you feel like it's getting a little
better
um I don't know
it might be getting a little better but
people stick to their crowd and theyself
that's it yeah no that's fair I think um
yeah I mean I don't know when I went
there I felt like everybody was [ __ ]
with each other it was it was good
people [ __ ] with each other but I'm just
talking about like on a deeper level
though no I get it on a deeper level
like we really gotta oh I was just lock
in come together and just take this [ __ ]
to a whole new level that's fair that's
fair man
um for you uh who are some of the up and
coming artists out of the city that
you're just a fan of
um
um oh [ __ ] I don't know
I don't know I like I like horse the one
I like I like Mari red
and um there's a few more other people
but I got them all repeat right now
though how's your brother doing he doing
good in good spirits in great spirits
yeah he's still locked up right he's
still locked up were you hoping he come
on 2023 okay and I say we hoping because
he got a sentence in January and it's
gonna be in a judge hand so when he gets
out you got to put him on the twitch
[ __ ] man of course he got to be the guy
who's holding down the gang while you're
[ __ ] on vacation I'm gonna have him
on that for sure you can't hold down the
grizzly gang online all the time by
yourself yeah yeah yeah you have like I
got guys on there though like you got
guys yeah my game be on it down for sure
do you have like guys that like you like
are these guys you've met in person or
are they like people here just know
digitally no some of them I just know
digits at least some of my men in person
though have you met any of these like
when you meet a guy who you've known
through the video games in person is it
kind of crazy to see what they look like
or who they are or I ain't gonna lie
it's been a couple people it's been a
couple people like damn this [ __ ]
crazy yeah like yeah
I ain't gonna say it but any children
yeah yeah I got I got a son yeah wait
wait wait wait yeah
so you have a son in the game oh no not
in the game other people got kids in the
game I got a son in real life though is
he on the game no no I mean I mean any
children like
a part of your gang that's what I'm
saying like I didn't admit some people
and they've been like 12 but yeah he's
like gang banging this [ __ ] hard enough
yeah like that should be crazy wow
they're like you're on Grizzly game
whatever they really ain't supposed to
be playing it oh they've been eight
Euros on that [ __ ] be folded I
admit them they were like Yeah I'm such
I'm like that's you what the [ __ ] it's
crazy that [ __ ] is wild yeah you ever
have them like try to DM you and then
you're like you see their profile like
oh this is what this [ __ ] look
like oh we gotta kick him out the gang
man no no it ain't never been a
situation like that no the only thing
that surprised me like when I finally
see him is to be real life like kids
sometimes yeah but yeah that's why I I
feel like like all these games online
are just so far past
my learning capabilities to be good at
them and I feel like GTA because I
played I beat GTA obviously but I've
never played online yeah so it's
different I definitely feel like it it
ain't a learning curve though I feel
like with GTA be easy because you're
just running around kind of the only
thing you got to do is just don't break
character that's the only thing that's
the Only Rule Don't Break characters
what if someone does then you get mad
they get exiled you get bent because you
you [ __ ] up the experience for
everybody else what the [ __ ] can I just
I could just go and watch you play right
on Twitch obviously yeah that's [ __ ]
amazing yeah yeah definitely Jesus I
love it man yeah actually the movie for
sure yeah I can't play like uh fortnite
or no no I can't I can't because it's
these little these little kids is too
good I'm starting too late yeah I don't
even play Call of Duty unless it's story
mode so listen you can play Call of Duty
you can actually get good at it you
gotta run with the right team bro
yeah I sucked until I started running
with the right thing most deals suck
yeah
damn that's fire
I got a screenshot it says I get not one
kill whole game
so that would be me because me when I
play fortnite I kind of run around and
hide yeah and wait for the circle to get
smaller and then I'll just go find a new
place and then I'll be like top 10
though yeah and I'd be like [ __ ] I made
it yeah you know what I'm saying but I
can't kill nobody I don't know how to
build nothing new you know see that's
why I can't focus for tonight because
you gotta build and all that I like Call
of Duty if I shoot at you ain't no
getting away from this but there's
hackers on there now it's a big hackers
on there for the longest yeah they said
that they're like the new uh policy is
uh you have to have a phone number for
your account so they can make sure I
don't know what what that's going to do
to cut it down they selling that [ __ ] I
think
um
that yeah the hackers you can't really
be a hacker yeah they're selling the hex
how much money you got on GTA in the
world like I got about 16 000 but I'm
I'm coming up though
in uh in your world yeah you're the
leader of the game you only got 16 bands
in GTA what's going on [ __ ] it's hard
it's [ __ ] up out there damn right now
do you just Rob people
yeah but see I ain't trying to rob
everybody because I got to create
relationships because people starting
this people starting to [ __ ] with me on
the street [ __ ] you know I got like a
half a brick I need to sell that I can't
be robbing people just so we know we're
very clear this is in the video game
yeah this is a video game yeah yeah yeah
yeah very cool
um you uh just left uh the bar stool
[ __ ] with Caleb Presley I'm a big fan of
him me too he's hilarious yeah how was
your experience with him actually it was
fire that sure was fun
um it was fun bro was Glennie balls
eating ice cream yes I asked him for
something did he give you some no
because they have another Bowl
um but but both of them don't I [ __ ]
with them that [ __ ] was fun it was funny
was it like uh uncomfortable
it went uncomfortable they definitely
was asking me some crazy [ __ ] though but
it wasn't uncomfortable though
it was fun it was literally like
hilarious for real yeah yeah it was hard
not to like be laughing and [ __ ] no I
bet yeah hey we got to stop the
interview real quick to tell you about
our newest partner to the podcast shout
out to our family at hardean Las Vegas
man listen uh the number one dispensary
in the world I don't give a [ __ ] man
craziest dispensary with the most
selection they got so much weed in this
[ __ ] place you go to Las Vegas you're
[ __ ] feeling good with your homies
it's recreational you're like damn I
could just go into a store and buy weed
yeah but you just can't go into any
store in Las Vegas to buy weeds you know
walk out with some [ __ ] [ __ ] no
you go to hard Dean tell them I sent you
all right make sure you follow them
online Harding underscore Las Vegas you
see it down there you see the
[ __ ] sweater we represent and
by the way can we shout out
to them for sending me this this bootleg
head podcast
thingy
what is this called
no no it's uh for cigars
humidor yeah the humidor now this is
what's great about it we might start
doing this for our smoking guests
you know we might have to bust open the
Hardy and humidor
and just get into some of these treats
you know what I'm saying a little bit of
the treaties you know straight from
Hardy in Las Vegas even I mean
these are totally props because you know
they're props but with that being said
when you go to Vegas telling bootleg
have sent you Jardin Las Vegas I'm
telling you it is like going to it's
like the Bentley of dispensaries it's so
nice the weed is the best the selection
is the best the bud tenders are the best
and yo make sure you shoot them a follow
Hardy and underscore Las Vegas go to
hardinglasvegas.com and when you're in
Vegas
go to hardine baby all right you already
know let's get back to the interview I'm
not be dying did you see the Aaron
Rodgers one
I see that one Aaron Rodgers is [ __ ]
high bloodshot red eyes and he's just
dying the whole [ __ ] time he's like
inaudible he was laughing so hard it was
so good yeah yeah I gotta watch that you
know Aaron Rodgers that's the reason why
yeah it was like from like the last
month okay right before the football
season started I gotta watch that you
know Aaron Rodgers be doing Ayahuasca
and [ __ ] he'd be [ __ ] tripping hard
man yeah yeah Aaron Rodgers that's
Wisconsin yeah Green Bay yeah yeah okay
he still play football right now yeah I
see you're not a football fan obviously
no no he'd be high like that he'd be
doing like hallucinogenics yeah okay
mushrooms and uh Ayahuasca yeah have you
ever have you ever done any of that no
I'm not sure I want to though you should
man yeah I want to why wouldn't you I
definitely want to I've heard great
things about it you're off papers right
yeah like you're a free man totally yeah
that's great yeah eat some shrooms yeah
and then
do the shroomed out episode of twitch
when you're at band that'd be crazy yeah
that'd be nice yeah man it's gonna be
like ready player one soon where you're
gonna have the whole [ __ ] thing
where you're wearing a suit and [ __ ]
yeah yeah I don't know you ever do the
VR
no I don't [ __ ] with the VR ever watch
VR porn no never not even again you
don't you don't own a [ __ ] Oculus no
I don't
if you are pouring fire it's not not
fire okay
okay
I put it on blueface right I interviewed
blueface and uh I just bought it he's
like let me see the VR points I was like
yeah whatever he looked it up and he
looked down he's like bro my dick is
white
so you got an Oculus here no no no not
here this was like when I first bought
it now it's inside my house honestly
it's just at my house on the charger all
the time I never use it so you don't
watch VR pouring no more you watch it on
your phone now I I literally watched VR
porn twice just because I was like ah
let me see what is I'm just curious so
you just wish it back over to the phone
right no I don't watch porn okay yeah
I'm married you know what I mean okay
yeah it's for experimental purposes
gotcha okay but you're like looking
around and you're like
this is crazy yeah like [ __ ] yeah now if
I wasn't married I probably
would never need a woman again yeah
because I just throw on the headset
just be locked in mm-hmm you know what I
mean yeah wherever I want to go I'm
there what you know what I'm saying yeah
yeah that's fire it's not bad man that's
fire it's definitely uh it's not bad
what got you into wanting to do films
I like TV shows bro I like movies I've
always liked movies and TV shows and
stuff like that and um I like how
the directors
make us feel some type of way
you know like who's your favorite
director
or whoever did Game of Thrones oh yeah I
mean Game of Thrones is great besides
season eight which was [ __ ] atrocious
exactly so but
him for example he make you hate
characters he make you love characters
yeah he make you want to watch the next
episode immediately of course you feel
what I'm saying so
that was interesting to me and I wanted
to kind of do that as well through music
I like that and then you know what else
too is like
you got to really get in that bag and
start writing your show to tell that
Detroit story from like the snowfall
perspective because I know a couple
homies that sold their their life to the
90s they just they're they're from the
streets and they've already gotten like
real TV deals because all these networks
are trying to do the next snowfall yeah
somebody got to tell that Detroit story
that's a fact the white tell them type
in hey the wire told the Baltimore side
you ever watched The Wire I do that's my
favorite show ever I do
are you trying to take 50 spot on Stars
so it's exclusive replacing 50 Cent
coming right up if you don't want that
I'll go 50 Cent as you should yeah
if stars and 50 hit me up I'm going 50
Cent of course 50 is a one I'm going 50
cents it's not the two yeah facts but
stars do need to you know I'm saying
feel that Gap because they left a big
gap when he left well all the shows are
gone yeah when he leaves it's like
what's next I don't know they had the
whole power Universe being black you
know obviously BMF
yeah so you love Game of Thrones
so you kind of wanted to apply
storytelling like a TV series to the
music side is it hard to pull that off
conceptually
because it's hard to pull that off on a
TV show it's not hard to pull it off for
me nah it's not nice
it's easy and um it's hard making a
regular song I was gonna say break down
like the chapters like somebody say make
a Club Banger right now right like the
[ __ ] I'm gonna go here and say yeah and
then it might not work and you don't
even be in the club exactly but if you
tell me make a chapters of the trenches
all right bet I can't tell your story
exactly you could do that with no not no
pun intended with no effort exactly
exactly exactly you see what I did there
yeah
um how much did you hate season 8 of
Game of Thrones did you hate it as much
as I did because it almost ruined the
whole series for me
I probably hated it more than everybody
it was so disappointing yeah bro because
I ain't wanted to end like that that
ain't the end and I wanted and then I
didn't want to end that quick like they
rushed so much yeah facts the fact that
all of them I feel like House of dragons
is rushed too though I only saw the
first episode I feel like it's Rush bro
like y'all skipping 10 years and [ __ ]
right now check this out what if I
wanted to see what happened through
those 10 years yeah I mean I think
that's what was great about the first
seven seasons of Game of Thrones is it
was so slow and methodical and it built
characters so slowly and then season
eight all of a sudden Daenerys is a
[ __ ] bad she's bad she's killing
innocent people the fact that the
[ __ ] war with the white walkers
lasted that should have been a whole
season right and [ __ ] should
have really died thanks by how you build
up this [ __ ] winter is coming the
whole show and then you blow the load so
fast it should have been they should
have been man that [ __ ] was the worst
bro that's the fact and I'm gonna tell
you right house of dragons
one episode
it's a little girl
that's the one I saw the first one now
look check this out not one episode
let's see a little girl and she liked it
right yeah experiencing herself the very
next episode she was a grown lady it was
a different character she had three kids
like God damn Jesus yeah I didn't see
that I wasn't ready for another version
of her
yeah I don't know I haven't I gotta I I
have no opinion I just know that Game of
Thrones season eight is a [ __ ] black
eye of all TV history yeah okay it's one
of the best shows ever and they [ __ ]
it up did you watch Dahmer I didn't I
mean it's pretty wild yeah sick [ __ ]
that guy I gotta go rewatch The Wire you
have to yeah when did you watch it how
long ago it's been like five years so I
rewatched it for the first time since
like 2010 during the pandemic like the
first like months of the pandemic Was it
crazy oh yeah it still was fire it's
even more fire like after everyone I was
like [ __ ] it's up there to me it's like
that and Breaking Bad is my two favorite
shows okay did you watch Breaking Bad I
didn't what I didn't see you breaking
bad it's about a [ __ ] teacher who
sells maps yeah because he has cancer
and he has to pay for his [ __ ] [ __ ]
damn do he beat the cancer well he had
so he was broke his [ __ ] house was
upside down he's a [ __ ] science
teacher in high school
and he needed to make money so his
brother-in-law is a DEA agent and takes
him on a Ride Along
and he notices while they're raiding a
house one of his ex students sneaks out
of the top roof
and he says and he didn't snitch on him
he just ran off he didn't say nothing
right and then his brother-in-law's like
yeah we just uh we just took you know
like 1.2 million dollars worth of meth
out of that house and and then the light
went off oh I'm a chemist I teach
chemistry
I can make meth and he made the best
[ __ ] in town the best [ __ ] okay
crazy that's on fire did he beat the
cancer though yeah he yeah listen man
you just gotta watch it bro okay it's
fire okay and then him and the student
who he saw Escape they partner up some
gangster [ __ ] bro that's why yeah I
gotta check that out it's [ __ ] ill
and then they did a spin-off called
Better Call Saul that's crazy better
cause I saw that was good too yeah yeah
better call us all yeah
yeah Yellowstone is not on that level
though relax just chill Yellowstone is
solid but it's like it's like it's like
surface level good it's like it's both
of these on Netflix yeah okay yeah
Breaking Bad and better call Salt but
you gotta watch Breaking Bad first then
you gotta watch Better Call Saul okay
yeah yeah and then and then don't watch
Dahmer it's disturbing it's just like
[ __ ] up
I got you yeah some Milwaukee [ __ ] I
don't know what they're doing in the
midwest over there but y'all serial
killers hit different over there damn
that was Milwaukee yeah now every city
in the midwest is super different though
too this is true very diverse like weird
super area like a bunch of Swing States
it's super different bro it's crazy
white people are different in Detroit I
went to a Tech Nine concert while I was
there for that week that white trash in
Detroit man I get it now hmm like how's
the white trash out here just this is
not Detroit white trash so when I was
sitting in there
off just the whole Eminem [ __ ] all
connected I was like yeah
white people I get it
yeah yeah a bunch of M M's if he never
would have popped off in this
[ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah white dudes with dirty [ __ ]
jinko jeans wife beaters and Detroit
tattoos on their neck yeah yeah going
around in his [ __ ] restaurants
terrible shout out to Amber this
restaurant was not good mom spaghetti it
was God awful did you get the spaghetti
yes I got both things I went there with
a baby Tron and uh we got the sandwich
and the and the spaghetti just to try
everything and it was what kind of
sandwich was it spaghetti sandwich
spaghetti sandwich was it was the was
this a spaghetti fire though oh no it's
terrible did it have me you ain't gonna
know meatballs in it of course how can
spaghetti be nasty like how can you [ __ ]
up spaghetti okay one easily
it tastes like
if I were to go to a white lady's house
who didn't know how to cook and she said
hey are you hungry we have some leftover
for spaghetti from a few days ago and
you said yes and then they put it in the
microwave and then they fed it to you
that's what it tastes like
yeah but you're vegan ish I'm vegan is
here
how's that going for you
um it's cool
I was saying like because you were like
man I'm trying to be vegan and most
people who are you know you're a big guy
most people go vegan to try to lose
weight and I'm like well you're still
kind of a big guy so how's it going like
what was the reason so
it's because I just wanted to eat
cleaner you know what I'm saying that
was like the most part I just want to
eat cleaner and if I lost weight then
that would have been a bonus well I just
want to eat cleaner though
did you end up eating cleaner did you
end up eating cereal and chips and [ __ ]
no I don't eat I I I eat a lot of vegan
food but here and there I have an oxtail
or right you know what I'm saying [ __ ]
like that so you uh Dibble and Dabble in
the vegan lifestyle yeah yeah I Dibble
in it yeah what's your favorite vegan
fake thing because you know they got
these vegan wings that aren't Wings it's
like just call them whatever they are I
can't use that [ __ ]
do you like fried chicken got to be
fried chicken I eat um possible burgers
or anything and possible Whopper is fire
it's better than a real Whopper I I
don't know about that have anybody here
had impossible Whopper
Burger King where you think they got
Whoppers
Mo you had the impossible Whopper
yeah it tastes better though it tastes
better tastes more charred more charred
hey I respect it would you rank uh
because Burger King is uh
as a guy who's a fellow guy who enjoys
fast food I want some Burger King though
[ __ ] with Burger King those chicken
fries
I was gonna ask you give me all the
major chains
major chains only rank the top five fast
food restaurants
hey what up y'all gotta stop the
interview to tell you about our family
at Odd Socks that's right go to
oddsoxofficial.com right now use the
promo code bootleg that's right bootleg
you will save 20 off at checkout now
listen we know that they have amazing
socks these are sour patch kids socks
these are hot Cheeto socks
Half Baked you know what I'm saying and
uh you know for those that like Snapple
so much so that you would wear socks
with snapple's logo on them and all my
Naruto fans they have the Naruto but
let's bust these boys out you know they
they got the underwear and the underwear
are crazy love the draws what do we have
here
oh oh we have we have Hey Arnold
underwear
these are [ __ ] amazing Jesus I'm
gonna wear these you know why I'm gonna
wear those oh because I have
Hey Arnold socks on you see what I did
there yeah that's right we out here
represent Odd Socks the most comfortable
socks in the world I promise you if you
get your Odd Socks Basics like these
these are the basics right those are uh
I mean you're not gonna get any better
than that you know what I mean the odd
Sox Basics are incredible all right so
uh that's my favorite I'm always wearing
a black or white pair of Odd Socks
Basics but uh don't like listen to me
try them out for yourself go to
oddsoxofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg save 20 off at checkout and
they got some new [ __ ] coming at the top
of the Year hmm I would say go to their
Instagram at oddsocks official
and just look at some of the shoes that
uh the owner's wearing in some of the
videos they may or may not be having
some slides coming out I don't know I
cannot confirm nor disconfirm but you
know they did put them on their
Instagram for a reason like a little
tidbit little little crumbs to what's
coming next year
plus they just dropped their monster
socks which I don't have any of those
here but it is Halloween season so go
[ __ ] with those you already know man odd
Sox official go [ __ ] with them on
Instagram go to oddsoxofficial.com and
use the promo code bootleg save 20 off a
checkout and when you do that you
support us you support the whole crew
over here at the bootlegate podcast so
let's get back to the interview
top fast food restaurants
Chick-fil-A it's the most consistent
number one the most consistent okay
Raising Cane's okay they bred there is
like no other it's the cane sauce yeah
that cane sauce hits different for sure
yeah he waiting on me to say in and out
I'm not gonna say it
so Raising Cane's Chick-fil-A I'm at a
great start right now
are you two for two for sure
um now things get hairy okay okay it's a
drop off now
Shake Shack really Shake Shack got fire
Ass Burgers and chicken sandwiches
but isn't Shake Shack there's no
drive-throughs not fast food
disqualified give me another Choice okay
now listen now listen right
and I'm gonna say McDonald's because
since we had McDonald's the first time
yeah to the last time
they always had the best fries
listen I got McDonald's at number one
you're preaching to the choir okay all
right it's just literally the greatest
fast food restaurant of all time you
ever had you ever had a fish for Lay
sandwich with Mac sauce I've had every
type of [ __ ] house
it was great it was beautiful okay get
the full slice of cheese okay bit yeah
boom boom boom what's next Burger King
okay
now we got the the five spot I don't
know you're putting Burger King in the
five oh yeah I don't know so we got the
top three
damn I want to say KFC but they chicken
fake
but I gotta fire chickens at Popeyes
Popeyes Popeyes some have drive-throughs
I'll I'll take it I Popeyes
Del Taco [ __ ] Adam
fifth spot
fifth spot
gotta have a drive-through gotta have a
drive-through
Starbucks
have respect
Starbucks you hate no Taco Bell though
Taco Bell bro let me tell you Taco Bell
Taco Bell is the type of person
tell me what type of person I am Taco
Bell is the type of person to do
something just because everybody else
doing that I see what you say I love
Taco Bell like oh and what world do Taco
Bell sell Fried Chicken
they have Fried Chicken now yes Wings
yeah yes wow they don't I never thought
I'd see that in my life I like Taco Bell
because it really feels like they're
just taking all the homies and just
getting them [ __ ] up on [ __ ]
Edibles and weed and they're like hey
what would y'all want to eat and then
they put that on the menu you know what
though that fiery Taco they had though
that [ __ ] was undefeated like
they put the Dorito on yeah of course
and then they put Fritos inside of
burritos and [ __ ] yeah nah fiery one
that was the one I like yeah I think
McDonald's is uh they still got them
they still got them yeah they got the
red tacos I might have to go grab one of
them yeah no for sure I might have the
greatest show and take the impossible
Whopper meet your mother in there have
you ever done that it's cross-pollinated
fast food streams
um like maybe you get the [ __ ] fries
from McDonald's and you go to Wendy's
and get a frosty that might be actually
crazy though imagine McDonald's fries
inside of the frosty from Wendy's that's
crazy yeah you get the best fries and
then you get the Frosty and you go boom
that's the fact I might have to see
what's up yeah well now we understand
why vegans kind of got you running in
place wait what yeah yeah yeah yeah I
feel like um
I like I was you ever had a corned beef
sandwich of course
after last I I can use a corned beef
sandwich right now you ever have chicken
beef
is that [ __ ] in a jar and you eat it
with gravy and toast it's like breakfast
yeah corned beef hash obviously with the
potatoes I never had chicken beef though
you ever like just you know they got the
can that was kind of like one of the
go-to meals just the canned corned beef
hash put it in a [ __ ] pan throw some
eggs on top yeah we bought the laundry
company and we're gonna have like fried
chicken in the can he got Hood about you
already so it's like the Hibachi
um wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
fried chicken in a can yeah you gotta
explain to me how that [ __ ] makes any
kind of sense that sounds like got him
so basically salmonella so we're gonna
fry the chicken
and we gonna put it in a can and
um we're gonna put paper towel in there
so the grease can catch you know what
I'm saying okay
um seal that [ __ ] up and it's gonna have
like a a weak expiration on it
so if it don't get bought in a week it's
over if you don't give up we eat it
you'll eat it yeah yeah have you thought
about doing a ghost kitchen thing what's
that so if you're going like uh
Postmates ubereats you probably notice
like Wiz Khalifa has his own restaurant
on there Khalid has a restaurant uh
Tiger has a restaurant
so it's essentially you would start your
own restaurant
and then a kitchen that isn't a real
restaurant it's just a kitchen like a
commercial kitchen they'll fulfill your
orders for you come up with your menu
you could call it like Grizzly bites or
whatever yeah yeah I feel like with your
with your following online like I feel
like the kids would be like yo [ __ ] yeah
and you could plug that [ __ ] on Twitch
all day oh [ __ ] that might be hard no
cat do it man you never did
um a weed uh weed strain I did in
Detroit it was exclusive in Detroit
though I never did one out here yeah but
I do want to do some [ __ ] out here
though
I do want to lose it out here I think
was we talking about that who's talking
about that I don't know
if you're gonna do the voice oh yeah I'm
gonna be dope yeah yeah
I was just talking about she's Asian she
has to know the backpack boys
Rob
by the way shout out to Gramercy they
just signed with the backpack boys
oh run Sky okay yeah okay get it
together man yeah called grizzly bears
okay grizzly bear is just fire Chrisley
Berry oh yeah heat Grizzly berries yeah
you got it too hard uh so talk about uh
the album slash film
so what is exactly the first of all how
long did it take you to record because
I'm sure are you recording at home
you're going to the studio like no I'm
going to Studio I never have a studio in
my house
um
I'm going to the studio took like seven
months right and it's basically like
because it's called chapters of the
trenches right and I'm just walking you
through like everything that happened in
the trenches not everything but some of
the stuff that happened every day what
are some of the chapters I saw one was
like robbery you got robbery yeah you
got Jay Antoine about two two guys in
the trenches Who coming up you know what
I'm saying you got Miss Evans about a
fine ass teacher and these young
students is trying to [ __ ] her yeah you
got um tears and tone by the uncle and a
nephew neph trying to get put on you
know yeah so that they battling that
um
yeah Shakespeare classic a little Hood
love story but the inside though he dies
both they die both of them end up living
eternally you know what I mean in heaven
hey we gotta stop the interview real
quick tell you about our partners at my
bookie that's right salute to the family
at my bookie all right it is so much
action to get in on right now in sports
we got the playoffs in baseball we got
NFL action every Sunday and NBA season
is upon us yes if you want to get in on
the action and make some of this money
with me I'll be gambling all damn day
I might have a problem with that being
said go to my bookie right now when you
sign up use the promo code bootleg and
they will match your deposit all right
that's right your first deposit when you
sign up with a new account when you use
that promo code bootleg they're gonna
match it all right that means if you put
in 500 bucks you get another 500 for
free to gamble with yeah all right I'm
loving uh some of the Futures too uh I
love the over on wins for the Sacramento
Kings and the NBA season coming up I
think they're going to have a good year
I'll also beta over on the Phoenix Suns
they're gonna have more than 52 and a
half wins what are we talking about plus
NFL action every Sunday let's get this
money go to my bookie right now sign up
with that promo code bootleg all right
when you do that they're matching your
first deposit off the rip no matter how
big or small let's run that [ __ ] up go
to my bookie right now use that promo
code bootleg and get your first deposit
matched free money to gamble with with
my bookie let's get back to the
interview uh any scamming records I
ain't got no scam records I ain't no
scammer though no I don't even know how
to use a scammer but you oh yeah if you
if you don't know about it then why
would you make a song about it yeah I
don't know matter of fact I could try to
I can I can I know what's going on so I
can I can kind of do it yeah oh I could
talk about how [ __ ] blew all that
money all that EDD I can talk about
things blew all that money
and now they willing to do whatever that
ppos [ __ ] ran out all that [ __ ] yeah
I knew so many people were just eating
during the pandemic I was like I don't I
had so many people trying to convince me
like bro easy I'm like bro ain't nothing
that easy
anybody try to convince you some money's
that easy I'm like you know what was
that bait from the feds it might have
been because they're arresting everybody
yeah they are definitely arresting
everybody there's a uh the song about
everything's on record and people
snitching yeah well you know what it is
it's like
allegedly there might have been people
that were paying homeless people for
their IDs and their social security
cards
and then getting their check sent
somewhere yeah that's a fact you know in
theory not the worst idea still a paper
trail still a paper trail because whose
address is it going to exactly 100
percent
100 was Miss Evans uh inspired by a real
teacher that you were trying to [ __ ]
when you were a kid
no
um that story came from my from my
fiancee okay and I'm in her hometown a
teacher had got like 20 something years
where's she from Saginaw Michigan okay
Saginaw is not too far from Detroit
right like an hour and a half yeah yeah
and um she was like you should make a
song about that and she gave me the idea
and I'm like damn you're right that's
tight you know and everybody can relate
to it well you're you're married now
though engaged basically married though
okay
so you're engaged
talk about losing pnb Rock who's
somebody who you were close with
man that was [ __ ] up bro that was hard
I feel like you lost a gene with friend
I feel like I lost a gene with friend
and [ __ ] and genuine friends in this
business is hard to come by yep you know
so that was that was tough for sure yeah
because I feel like you were with him
the day before maybe
yeah at the um engagement party yeah
that's why I thought you were married
because I thought that was your wedding
because it looked like you know you know
that was that was the engagement party
wow do you remember uh
like obviously PMB was one of those guys
who he recorded here all the time he was
just a solid [ __ ] dude man and he was
one of those guys like you said it was
like super loyal very like you know like
you said like a lot of dudes got that
industry [ __ ] on him where it's like
they gonna [ __ ] with you because they're
because because it makes sense for them
it benefits them at the moment and pnb
was never that guy no face that's a fact
100 man that's a fact bro uh how did you
know that your girl was the one man
um I just knew it yeah I just knew it
you know was anything particular was it
her cooking was it just the way she uh
it wasn't in particular because all that
[ __ ] go away yeah I hope the cooking
doesn't go away because my wife's a hell
of a cook I hope it can go away my
grandma was the best cook in the world
she can't it fell off yeah oh [ __ ] had
some [ __ ] not so long ago and I was like
damn grandma what happened yeah yeah
but everything go away yeah
is this something like did you ever
foresee yourself settling down
um yeah because I always wanted a
functional life I grew up so
dysfunctional yeah I always want to just
function functional
peace you know what I'm saying [ __ ] like
that so yeah yeah that's dope man well
congratulations appreciate it yeah for
sure
um on this project any features
I got baby Grizzly on there shout out to
your brother that's it that's it no
features I love it no features I Love It
I Don't Need No features though yeah
because it's like
I don't know I don't want no features
unless it makes sense yeah that's fair I
would like to get Alicia Keys
awesome [ __ ]
it's not that's pretty I think that's
realistic yeah
you know I always wonder when you have a
song like first day out and now everyone
makes a first day out when they get out
of jail everybody's got a first day out
if you've done jail time you get out and
you drop a song called first day out
yeah yeah yeah it's pretty crazy
um but your song is one of those songs
that
forever will get played in the club
no matter what club you go to it's like
Dreams and Nightmares is going to play
first day out is going to play it is
like one of those iconic records that
it's just it's just a staple
um what's it like having one of those
you ever get tired of the song like you
know what I'm saying come on man I thank
God for that it's a blessing bro change
your life yeah change my life it's a
blessing it's a blessing to have that
for sure yeah you know what I'm saying
feel good yeah cause it's like I feel
like at least in the last 10 years
I don't know like songs that are I mean
because now we're going on five years
that song's been out has it been five
years it's been it's been six years
it'll be six years in November yeah
there's not a lot of songs that are six
years old still getting played peak
hours in the club right now and like
when you go it's not like they're
playing it just because you're there
it's like no they're gonna play anyway I
don't even remember what songs came out
around that same time really the only
other song um is Dreams and Nightmares
that came out in 2012 though I know but
I mean that's like that old or and then
obviously like depending on where you're
at a little whistle you know Juvenile
Back That Ass Up You know but on some
like if you're like I'm talking about
peak hour [ __ ] yeah yeah facts yeah for
sure yeah shout out to uh yeah shout out
to that recommend it's definitely a
classic uh for you man where do you see
yourself going next with the music [ __ ]
are you focused more on like building
out the the everything else
I want to feel in the Gap in hip-hop
okay what's your storytelling yeah you
know what I'm saying that's a gap
not a lot of people doing that right now
not a lot of people doing it Kendrick
did a great job on his new album with
some some of the records on there yeah
definitely you know kindergarten is
doing a great job
you know but that's a gap bro that
nobody's feeling
especially a whole project yeah nobody's
doing that they used to do that [ __ ]
back in the day like there was a a
prince Paul album called uh [ __ ] 40
thieves I'm [ __ ] up the name the
whole album was like a movie yeah front
to back yeah but no one's doing that
anymore people aren't worried about that
[ __ ] because they want to [ __ ] they
want to catch a [ __ ] Tick Tock record
they want to go viral they want to you
know they're not worried about like
bodies record though anything can be
we've seen that yeah anything can be a
club record anything could be a tick
tock record I feel like people just got
to go in there and be creative be true
to themselves and you don't know what
can happen yeah you go in there and try
some specific [ __ ] and it won't work
that's real have you felt you thought
that like the difference when you're
going in like try to force the record as
opposed to just going to do what you
want
yeah yeah there's no way you knew first
day out was going to be as big as it was
when you recorded it I had no idea bro
yeah I would have been so happy to come
on I would have been like I ain't doing
nothing fighting right nothing in here I
gotta hurry up and get home and drop
this song because I know what it's gonna
do that's beautiful man hey what up
y'all bootleg cab here uh we got to
interrupt the interview and tell you
about our family at Blue Chew look if
you go to bluetooth.com right now use
the promo code bootleg to sign up and
you will get your first month of blue
chew for free that's right they're gonna
give you the first month of blue chew
for free all you got to do is pay five
dollars in shipping and you're gonna get
delivered right to your door some great
[ __ ] for your dick let me tell you what
it is all right if you're dealing with
erectile dysfunction if you're dealing
with any sort of stress and you just
need an extra little uh you know a
little performance enhancer if you will
all right for you Johnson down there all
you got to do is go to Bluetooth uh and
use that promo code bootleg and it's
coming straight to your door the same
active ingredient as Viagra as Cialis
and then the new mint chewable breaking
news there is a new mint chewable that
blue chew has just introduced to the
marketplace and it has the same active
ingredient as Levitra and stackson I'm
going to try to tell you about this
active ingredient it's VAR denafil
but
try it out supposed to be a little more
potent than a normal blue shoe whatever
you need regular blue chew the new mint
chewable whatever it is you're gonna
knock it out the [ __ ] Park all right
look Barry Bonds needed a little
performance enhancing when he uh hit 73
home runs back in the day he holds the
record still you might need a little
performance enhancement in the bedroom
your lady will thank you your wife will
thank you your boyfriend will thank you
whatever the [ __ ] you're into we're not
judging over here at the Boolean cat
podcast but I am judging you if you
don't go to Bluetooth right now and sign
up with that promo code bootleg and get
a month for free try it out it's
literally free all right let's get back
to the interview
um anything else uh obviously uh is the
project out Friday or next Friday this
Friday it's coming out this way so by
the time you watch this it'll be out
yeah go run it up yeah go run it up
chapters in the trenches you know what
I'm saying give us some feedback let us
know what your favorite story is all
that good [ __ ] what's your favorite
right now off of the album Miss Evans
Miss Evans nice for sure does she end up
[ __ ] the students you're going to
jail yeah damn so she's a so your face
favorite songs about a pedophile went to
jail for rape and she pregnant [ __ ]
she's a rapist for sure statutory rapist
little better than just plain rapist but
still a rapist nonetheless any rapist is
a rapists a hundred percent I agree
so uh I think I thank God though bro
because it's like
God gave me the ability to do this yeah
you know so I thank God for that I just
want to plug that in there no man that's
beautiful um before you go obviously you
want to get into the movie [ __ ] what is
what are your favorite give me your top
three movies all time top three movies
yes
The Godfather series okay we'll combine
them all
um
you ever seen due date yeah I've seen
due date yeah with uh Robert Downey Jr
and Zach Galifianakis yeah do they
Indecent Proposal okay now that's a very
diverse three yeah I had to give you
author I can just do all straight
gangster movies nah I love it all
straight funny movies yeah did a love
story yep gangster [ __ ]
funny [ __ ] there it is and it's probably
the top of those categories too I
disagree wholeheartedly about due date
it was okay due date was funny bro it
was funny but it wasn't like funny that
[ __ ] was hilarious it was funny he drunk
his father's ashes right no it was funny
yeah and when he was realized he told me
because he drunk the eggs he drunk some
more eggs to stop this I don't know if I
don't know if I'd even put it in my top
30 funny movies so what's your top three
funny I need your top five funny movies
Friday
old school
first old school with Will Ferrell okay
I'm gonna throw another Will Ferrell
movie in there
Step Brothers Step Brothers okay
super bad
super bad The Big Lebowski the poster
that's my favorite movie ever it's
technically accommodates behind you
that's my favorite movie of all time
that's funny it is my favorite movie
ever it's funny though yeah it's funny
it's funny as [ __ ] yeah it's the whole
movie starts with these so there's two
people named Jeffrey Lebowski who live
in LA one of them is a millionaire one
of them is like a [ __ ] loner who's
broke as [ __ ] living off unemployment
and this the millionaire owes somebody
like a hundred thousand dollars so the
goons knocked down the cheap dude's door
beat the [ __ ] out of him piss on his rug
not realizing they got the wrong Jeffrey
Lebowski until it's too late they
already pissed on his rug so the poor
Jeffrey Lebowski really loved his rug
because it tied the room together
so he takes the rug he rolls it up and
he finds the rich Jeffrey Lebowski it's
this old white guy he brings the Piston
rug to his house
gets a meeting with him and says hey I'd
like you to cover the cost of my rug
because they were looking for you not me
man and I love my rug
and that's it and then it just it's wild
from there it goes into like some wild
[ __ ] it's crazy it's such a wild movie
we're kind of we I find that movie yet
Netflix Amazon Prime I don't know if
it's on Netflix but it might be on um
Amazon yeah I mean I own like seven
versions of it so I just give you one I
got it on Blu-ray I got it on [ __ ]
special edition Blu-ray I got it I'm
[ __ ] I bought it online
really good to me it's it's my favorite
movie of all time okay gotcha yeah and
then I gotta give you one more comedy uh
let's do uh
[ __ ] comedy
I would say yeah I already said Friday
uh
uh
how high was great how high was like
nostalgic for me but I honestly think
like uh
hangover was up there man because
hangover oh [ __ ] yeah hangover was funny
the first one yeah the next two or
whatever but the first one was pretty
wild you think about bad boys three
it was all right Bad Boys 2 was my
favorite yeah that was three was a
little kind of a letdown we waited all
this [ __ ] time just for the movie to
be in
did you like it I think I think they did
great on the graphics I mean yeah but
[ __ ] the graphics I wanted to laugh Bad
Boys 2 is the best one though Bad Boys
you're the best one for sure where the
little dude knocks on the door trying to
take his daughter on a date and they
[ __ ] break that [ __ ] is Iconic yeah
that's classic for sure and he's wearing
the Tim Hardaway Heat jersey the whole
[ __ ] movie that [ __ ] just back to my
childhood man yeah there it is man look
I appreciate you going up the new
project uh there's gonna be like
obviously visuals to go along with
everything right everything yeah it's
all on YouTube yeah or is it gonna be
dropping all at once
or separately it's we've already been
dropping something we dropped some
shingles prior to it coming out and um
it's gonna come out like
every other day or some [ __ ] like that
and if people want to join your server
how does that happen
grizzlyworldrp.com so if I wanted to get
into your gang
let's say I just wanted to get in man I
got to make sure I don't break character
and I gotta go do I gotta go kill
somebody for you maybe yeah just send me
on a mission I'll make it happen I might
I might hear you rob a bank I don't know
should I come in I'm in I'm in yeah t
Grizzly my brother appreciate you man
yes sir appreciate you bro fire